[Müzik]
Evet son konuşmacı olarak burada olmak
heyecan verici Hermes der ki
gök kubbenin altında yeni ve söylenmeyen
söz yoktur Ben 20 yüzyıldan buraya
geldim 1956 doğumluyum bu doğum tarihimi
söylemeyi şunun için istiyorum çünkü
kadından çok bahsedeceğim Türkiye'nin
gelişim süreçlerinden bahsedeceğim Çünkü
hayatı değiştirmekle ilgili Yola
çıktığım yaşım 18'dir Sevgili babam
benim bir erkek çocuk olarak dünyaya
gelmemi çok arzu etmiş
benden 11 yaş büyük abim evde olan
doğumu babama müjdelediğinde bir kızımız
oldu dediğimde babam göklere uçmuş o
kadar sevinmiş o kadar neşe dolu olmuş
ki ben bu hikayeyle büyüdüm bu hikaye
bana hızlı uyum sağlamayı öğretti Ben
baba tarafından çukurovalıyım umudumun
bittiği yerde inadım başlar üniversite
çağları bugün burada sahneye çıkan işte
20 yüzyıldan gelen insanların hep
bahsettiği gibi
anarşinin çok yoğun olduğu zamanlardı
Ben üniversitede
1974-1978 yılları arasında bulundum Ama
o kadar çok devamla ilgili kesintileri
uğruyordu ki çalışmakla ilgili bir karar
verdim Bu benim Özgür irademle aldığım
bir karardı
hakikaten karar almak özgürlüktür karar
aldığınız anda kendinizi böyle Kuşlar
Gibi edersiniz O zaman belki iş bulmak
daha mı kolaydı bilmiyorum
üniversitede İktisat okuyordum işletme
okuyordum Dolayısıyla bankaya müracaat
ettim Bana 2-3 tane ticari aritmetik
problemi çözdürdüler ve beni bankaya
kabul ettiler 18 yaşındayım bankanın en
genç
en küçük çalışanıyım çok heyecanlıyım ve
o yolda başladık O zamanlar dövize
çevrilebilir mevduat hesapları vardı
beni kambiyoçya yaptılar Çünkü ben
İngilizce biliyordum Ee
kambiyotu oldum ama hiç böyle şey yok
yani dilimizi falan da kullanamıyoruz o
bende bir Merak uyandırdı Ben yurt
dışında bir burs alarak uluslararası
finansman hakkında bir şeyler öğrenmek
istiyordum
bu yolculuk devam ederken Tabii Okul iş
hayatı Bu arada bilmiyorum bizler çok mu
böyle elimizde hızlı hızlı tutardık
sevgilim var evlendim de Ama hiç bu
yoldan vazgeçmedim Londra merkezli bir
konsorsuyum bankasının bursunu kazandım
bu bursu kazandığımda o güne kadar
özgürce
yaratmış olduğum hareket alanımın bir
karar noktasına gelmiştim Tamam çok
istediğim bir şeyi
özgürce yürüyerek
kazanmıştım ama bir sorumluluğum vardı
Bir ailem vardı 3 yaşında bir oğlum
vardı ama o noktada Hayat arkadaşım
devreye girdi ve bana dedi ki; Sen
kendini gerçekleştirmelisin dur ve ben
Londra'nın yolunu tuttum Ee genel
eğitimlerden sonra bize branşlaşma öyle
alakalı alan seçmekle alakalı bir
seçenek ortaya koydular Ben tabii ki bu
Anarşi dönemleri Ee 82 Ee seçimlerinden
sonra Özal'ın başbakanlığı Elbette Ben
de bütün bu süreci yaşıyordum Ama şunu
çok idrakinde değildim
4 saat dediler şey var size süre
veriyoruz bu 4 saatin sonunda bize
kararınızı bildireceksiniz
delfideki Apollon tapınağının
biliyorsunuz girişinde kendini tanı
yazar kendime sorular sormaya başladım
Ben kimim
yeteneklerimle bunu yapabilir miyim 4
saatte varmadan kararımı bildirdim
Türkiye'ye döndüğümde yeni bir mesleğim
vardı tabi şantiyeler de olmam gerekiyor
yeni Turizm yatırımcılarını bulmam
gerekiyor bahsettiğim yıl
1985 pek çok yatırımlar var tabii Bu
arada orada öğrendiğim bana öğretilen
hiçbir
değerlendirme kriteri Türkiye'ye uymuyor
yani işte uluslararası anlaşmalarla
alakalı Uluslararası anlaşmaların
manuelleri yok hiçbir pratiği yok Peki
bu krediye kim teminat verecek Bunlar
hiç ortaya çıkartılmamış iki yine karar
almam gerekiyordu birincisi
irtibat kurup Ben ne yapacağım uymuyor
demem vardı bir diğeri de orada
öğrendiklerime ben buradakilerle
harmanlarım Nitekim başardım
duyulmaya başlandı şantiyeleri
dolaşıyorum karnım burnumda Bu sırada
o devrin Devlet bakanı bana bir haber
geldi Davet ettiler beni gittik
beni şöyle karşıladı
bir kadın varmış dediler
Kredi getiriyormuş bizim araziyi tahsis
ettiğimiz x'e de kredi getirmiş Bir
bakalım bu Kimmiş dedim dedi çok
şaşırmıştım beni mi anlayacaktı acaba
getirdiğim biz ya da Üzerinde
çalıştığımız krediyi mi ki Arkadaşlar bu
benim getirmiş olduğum yani yetkilisi
olduğum bu sistem daha sonra bankaların
sendikasyon kredileriydi hala aklımı
almaz savaşlar var yıl 1991 oldu Körfez
krisi Türkiye riskli ülkeler arasına
alındı Ve bana bir gecede işsiz
kaldığımı bilgisi geldi işsiz kaldık ama
oradan çıkmak lazım Benim babam da iyi
bir girişimciydi köy enstitülerin
ilköğretim öğretmenlerinden girişimci
ayrılmış kendi işini yapmış Türkiye'nin
de ilk sunta üreticilerindendir Fakat o
kadar çok konuştu kalktı ki her
seferinde her düştüğünde kalkardı
küllerinden yeniden doğardı ve bize hep
akşam duamız şuydu ey hak Bir torba
altın bırak Öge Ertuğrul
Kuran kurucu ortağı benim
tek imzayı etkisiyle Beni
görevlendirdiler ilk genel müdürlüğü
yaptım işte orada da kadın olmanın
zorlukları başladı
erkekler sistem büyümeye başladı
erkekler Akşamları yemeklere gidiyorlar
karar alıyorlar tek imza yetkisi bende
Sabah gelip Bana diyorlar ki bunu
uygular
geldiler ve yapıp yapamayacağını
birlikte tartıştık
o fizibilitelerini yaptım
Onun olabileceğini Ee anlattım çok tatlı
çok saygılı bir adamdı ama o kadar erkek
Egemen bir sistemin içinden gelmişti ki
böyle coşunca ulan abi derdi bana
Evet bugün burada olmak onun ruhunu Şad
etmek hakikaten bana iyi geldi Enes'e de
sevgilerimi iletiyorum bu fırsatı
verdiği için bütün bu sistem içerisinde
mesela istihdam politikamda kadınlar
öncelikli idi bütün
departmanlarda
yiyecek içecek var kaptanları
kadınlardan seçiyordum ama kadınların
düşünüldüğü kötü durumda hep erkek oldu
Hep böyle
çalıştık
eğitimsiz elemanlar vardı ve çok
dezavantajlı da gruplar vardı ve ben bir
karar verdim bir sosyal sorumluluk
üstlendim o tarihten sonra da kendime bu
sosyal sorumluluk işlerine adadım
mahlasımın bir aralar bu olduğunu
düşünürdüm çünkü hep bu kim bu yapıyor
buna söyleyin Bu kadın kim falan yani
Dolayısıyla mahlası bu idi Eee ve
Antalya'da ekonomiyi yeni şekilleniyordu
bahsettiğim yıllar dediğim gibi 90'lı
yılların başı ve o zaman kentte bu kadar
çok şey yoktu II sivil toplum kurumu yok
idi Eee asyası buldum kapısını çaldım
yönetim kurulunun toplandığı bir tarihte
beni gördükleri vakit dediler ki kapıda
adamları yazıyor Ne iş
anlattım işte neler yapabiliriz neden
buradayım Ee yok dediler yani sizi
üye yapamayız fakat
saygılı davrandılar bana netlerdi o
hoşuma gitti ve inadım devreye girdi
1994 yılında Beni üye yaptılar liderler
ayak izlerini takip etmezler ayak izleri
bırakarak yürürler bu beni bıraktığım
bir ayak izi gibi gelir gençlere hep
böyle meslekleri empoze ediyoruz Halbuki
girişimcilik bir kariyer yolu 21 yıldan
bu yana gençler gençleri girişimciliğe
teşvik etmek için girişimcilikle ilgili
çalışıyorum
eğitimlerle ilgili kilometre hesabı
yapamıyorum Bütün Türkiye'yi dolaştım ve
bilirsiniz mesleki eğitim
yasasında işletmelerin içerisinde eğitim
birimleri açmak vardı ben bunu
başlattığımda 2006 yılıydı Ee Birleşmiş
Milletler Eee
sürdürülebilir kalkınma amaçlarını
açıkladığında
2015'te ben bu çocukları toplayarak
bütün Türkiye'den ikna ederek
otellerde zincir otellerde kendi
otelimize dahil olmak üzere
eğitim birimleri açmak suretiyle
katkıda bulundum
insana yakışır İş olarak Birleşmiş
Milletler tarafından fark edilen bu
çalışma nedeniyle de
ödüle layık görüldüm daha sonra Garanti
Bankası ve Ekonomist dergisinin kadın
girişimciler yarışmasında yine ödüle
layık görüldüm Eee şimdi de gençlerle
birlikte girişimcilik eğitimlerini
yapıyoruz bugün Bu salonda onlar var
sevgili Emrah'la işbirlikleri yapıyoruz
beni bu topraklar çağırdı Çünkü bu
topraklarda prenseye Magna var perge'nin
kadını dünyanın ilk belediye başkanı bu
kadın ama geleneklerine göre kocasını ve
babasının zenginliğiyle mütevazı bir
hayat yaşayabilirdi ama bunu tercih
etmedi o kadın
belediye başkanlığında şehrin imarından
sanatına kadar
işte Gök kubbede yankılanan sesini
bırakarak gitti Ben şimdi vurdurun bir
köyünde yaşıyorum perma kültürle bir
orman köyünde yaşıyorum ben artık Bütün
hayatımı Bundan sonrasını gençlere
çocuklara kök kadınlarına kadın erkek
eşitliğine köy okullarını dolaşarak
anlatmakla ilgili bir misyon Ee edindim
dolayısıyla bir orman köyünde Ee
yaşamaya başladım Doğa önemli orada da
beni Burdur hacılardaki Kibele davet
etti Dolayısıyla bu topraklar öyle
zengin ki hepimize ilham veriyor ve
hepimiz bu topraklardaki Bu kültür
varlığına hazinelere baktığımız zaman
Eee
kendimize yol bulabiliriz
zerdüş sormuş dünyada en hoş Ee şey
nedir diye Ee
Ah işte şeyde cevap vermiş ona dünyada
en hoş şey insanın kendini geliştirmesi
ve kendisini aşmasıdır hazinelerine
ulaşmasıdır çok teşekkür ediyorum
[Alkış]
[Müzik]